[Music]
[Applause]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to and yes
you read that correctly we are reviewing
Jurassic world but you might be
wondering how the hell can we do that
it's still in theaters well this oughta
explain it hello
I bet you're wondering why we're
reviewing this movie now instead of
waiting for it to come to DVD we'll the
answer is quite simple you see how a
witness sees us as a threat
taking down several of our videos on
YouTube because they forgot reviews are
part of fair use some of these videos
have been put back but others aren't
just seen as too dangerous for your
French our minds to handle Plus every
single time we've done a Jurassic Park
movie even if we end up praising it
Hollywood has always taken it down by
mr. glasses I have a question why if it
isn't my good friend mr. puppy the puppy
what's on your mind mr. puppy as in
Hollywood realize that by doing this
they look incredibly desperate and
unprofessional I mean even your reviews
of bad movies have led to higher sales
due to your exposure Oh
mr. puppy Hollywood has more important
things to worry about than that well
what's more important than freedom of
speech being threatened by insecure
goons complaining how their freedom of
speech is being threatened by a bunch of
insecure goons you're kidding right well
as we said before the review must go on
I mean do they know the meaning of iron
so rather than do a review just to have
it taken down anyway they do remember
soap on Napster right you're going to
reenact scenes from the movie to give
you a better idea of what we're talking
about but mr. glasses the clips allow
people to judge the film for themselves
well your reenactments leave an
emotional even bitter mark on the
material being reviewed none whatsoever
gee I guess the only thing we can do now
is wait for Hollywood to finally grow up
I'm not holding my breath
so enjoy our incredibly unbiased review
of true
well you know your accent sounds a lot
like Cary Elwes with a dump truck shut
up his nose enjoy your the man reviewing
the Jurassic Park movies has been a big
tradition around here we're not gonna
let Hollywood stop it so we're have them
wait for it to come out on DVD we're
just gonna jump right into it this is
our take on Jurassic world the movie
opens up with our main star at the film
not Chris Pratt is Owen not Bryce Dallas
Howard is Claire not even really the
dinosaurs no the star of the movie is
the park
the amount of detail they put into this
place is incredible we finally see it
open it's like Disney World only lets
people probably die it's phenomenal so I
know what you're thinking if the park
looks this good so many years after the
original imagine what the goddamn
dinosaurs must look like it's been 22
years since the first film's
groundbreaking effects so how the hell
are they gonna look in that face up like
wow do they suck in some of the worst CG
the movies have ever cranked out they
look like cardboard cutouts no wait even
that would have some three-dimensional
qualities to them they look like mist
like a cloud of fog in the shape of a
dinosaur there's a scene where kid is
looking at dinosaurs through a
viewfinder which by the way you're 13
what the fuck you doing looking for a
viewfinder and even look more
three-dimensional than the ones in the
movie any wonder why because I was right
there it was really fucking there and
they okay their little models and they
don't look very convincing but I feel
like I can touch them I feel like they
could touch any of these answers and I
don't want to touch dinosaurs but
nevertheless I sure I won't be able to
feel like I competitor it that's the
wonder of Jurassic Park and here's the
thing I'm actually not anti CGI
I mean ex machina she looked like a real
robot Madagascar totally made me believe
that David Schwimmer could act but with
the other Jurassic Park movies to use
animatronic and CGI this fools the eye
it makes a more of a grand illusion
we've gotten too used to CGI so when we
see it we know it's CGI and we know it's
not there but here's the other weird
thing they said they use animatronics in
this movie but outside of a scene with
littlefoot's mother dies they all look
flat and unconvincing how can this be if
they used animatronics in my opinion
they see cheat over the animatronics
they look at the animatronics that say
the Raptors in the muzzle cages and say
you know what I want the eyes to blink a
little different or the mouth to move a
little more let's paint CG all over that
shit and now there's a veil of fake all
over what used to be believable but I
know what you're thinking who cares I
mean really in the grand scheme of
things who cares we've got to see cool
dinosaurs do cool dinosaur things even
they look at a fake we want them to do
cool things right well I can't take that
argument and store it away here for
later because trust me they'll come back
in in a bit of time but let's actually
get to the story now that the park has
been open for a while people it seems
have gotten too used to dinosaurs oh my
god this black chick who's a white chick
is white chick I felt somebody rude on
the Internet oh my god no-ho-ho that's
right they've actually gotten bored with
them the CEO of the park named Simon and
a manager of the park named Claire
trying to figure out how to fix this we
need to up the sales I need you to make
me a dinosaur so badass that if it
escaped we couldn't possibly stop it
okay now we're talking we've seen Rapids
and Sega sources before this is creating
a brand new dinosaur specifically to
look awesome Dale that's a fine line
rule there's not like they did before
anyway I mean the Dilophosaurus yeah you
know that but they're using science to
create whatever the hell they want
by God imagine what you could do with
this the body of a t-rex the wings of a
pterodactyl the neck of a brontosaurus
the head of the Triceratops blood is
four hands and hey just to sell more
tickets
give it bazooka boobs come on we're
clearly in bullshit science here we can
do whatever we want
okay I know they're not gonna make
something quite like that but it's gonna
look amazing and they've been building
it up in this movie for quite a bit so
after tricking the security guard like
an 80s prison movie no really he's got
the sandwich and everything what does
this monstrous terrifying abomination of
science look like
a big Raptor I'm a new dinosaur yep
it's about so impressive as you can
imagine you know that Photoshop tool you
can use to make things bigger that's
pretty much all they used except they
gave them a few more bumps on the back
and made them a little paler whoo
even the made-up name is abort we're
calling him indominus rex because it's
easier to pronounce you know what's even
easier to pronounce co2 and that's what
I'm calling him I'm calling in the co2
asaurus they openly admit it's trying to
be something bigger and better than the
t-rex but it looks so boring and fake it
can't measure up but actually to cook to
is credit it can do some cool things
like camouflage lower its body heat
which of course the scientists have no
fucking idea about oh my god we've
watched him from birth kept him in
captivity you know everything there is
to know about him how can we possibly
know everything there is to know about
him this is where the two kids come in
because by ship we always need fucking
kids in these movies but through their
credit they're not that bad it's more
the idiot adults that surround him you
see their parents are getting a divorce
oh yeah sorry so they're spending the
weekend with their aunt Claire who's
obviously a little busy herself hi
Claire I just wanted to make sure the
boys are okay oh well actually they're
not around me right now so I'm trying to
make sure that the park doesn't eat it
right now you're calling me during your
divorce hearing actually don't call me
when you're busy with that that's a
touch more important important Oh t-rex
Aidan baby you gotta go of course the
kids aren't alright because they're
written like little dumb asses that go
off into restricted areas and they're
American Gladiator ball that for some
reason has no track okay taking out the
obvious safety of the two people inside
especially to children without an adult
in a ball without a track how is this
safe for the dinosaurs and you see
people and go-karts imagine soaring
animals in that
but come to Grantham and again because
you never believe anything is there it's
not the least that frightening yet the
boys end up escaping so Claire tells
Olin the Raptor trainer about her
missing kids in coat - OH
after they share some amazing on-screen
chemistry we did it once remember sure
do and that's it
that was the on-screen chemistry on the
one hand unhappy they didn't argue like
those dysfunctional pussies and twister
but on the other hand why have them
interested in each other at all I mean
I'm like Ed like the chemistry in the
first film was that great but they at
least talked and awed and smiled and
shit like that
here they barely even look at each other
they sure won kids in the middle of the
film but then go back to acting like
they're not a couple again it's entirely
pointless I mean fucking bizarre concept
but if you have a dude and a chick in a
movie they don't always have to hook up
if you got a romance great but it's not
like a checklist in aliens Ripley
doesn't need to turn to Bishop and be
like I love you it'd be totally out of
nowhere and just wouldn't fit and I know
what you're thinking that's as crazy as
the part CEO flying a helicopter into
certain death you probably weren't
thinking that by near the segue the
owner decides he wants to help stop co2
by flying a helicopter to shoot at it
people played this triumphant music like
yeah he's doing the smart thing but
despite everybody telling him he's gonna
end up dying he eventually ends up dead
oh no yeah for a businessman nose brigde
moving this part
[Applause]
[Music]
you
this leads to a bunch of pterodactyls
being released and okay
remember that argument I was talking
about before about having the dinosaurs
only do cool stuff well here let's bring
them in the back end this is the cool
stuff I'm talking about the pterodactyls
are attacking people why is this awesome
because it's taking it to the next level
we've seen dinosaurs eat scientists and
people with guns in the jungle and we're
sick to death of it here even though
it's obviously fake it still looks
really cool they do is a legitimately
creative awesome stuff
they pick up civilians fight over them
drop them into the water only to have
other dinosaurs eat them there it's
fucking fantastic
even Claire machine guns found the one
that done saving all one's life but of
course the little kids are like do you
want to go with you Wow thanks that's
really great to hear okay you little
shits if I saw my aunt machine guns down
a pterodactyl you better hide behind her
skirt and ass
so okay all the people in the park are
in one location at all you can eat Dino
buffet just waiting to be ripped to
shreds the opportunities right
themselves what terrifyingly awesome
thing we never see those people again
they just stay in this one giant spot
this fucking salad bar of deliciousness
and we never ever touch them again what
do they do next
well something completely different
really new you've never seen this in
Jurassic Park movie psycho hunting
dinosaurs in the jungle right Ronnie
pushing the fucking ammo up here because
hey remember there's an evil scientific
hybrid that needs to be stopped
oh I'm not talking about the dinosaur
I'm talking about Vincent D'Onofrio
being successfully combined with John
Malkovich and every early 90s villain
ever
I want to weaponize these Raptors
because I'm the obvious bad guy I adjust
my belt buckle all the time no we don't
care we don't care we just have seen
where pterodactyls played hot potato
with people's heads why would we care we
know he's the bad guy we know he's going
to die we know that man sucks
so can we stop repeating what we've seen
a fuck ton of times and the other films
can we please give some new developments
Oh am I talking about one of the biggest
developments in the film is coming up
and I mean this is like a huge twist
they've been building up
they use the Raptors to find co2 and
somehow think these tiny things are
gonna take it down when they finally put
two and two together and remember this
is a big shock my god that dinosaur that
looks like a raptor acts like a raptor
sounds like a raptor and moves like a
raptor I think it's you goddamn moron
you know the sponge dinosaurs but the
ones you just add water to make them
grow bigger
well don't show that to anybody here
it'll completely blow their minds
they'll be like what's that oh come on
everybody knows that oh yeah I don't
know my god I'm amazing at what I do
so big shock a raptor attacks D'Onofrio
offscreen race pg-13 to death leaving
only our main stars left
well them and thousands of other people
next door but that'd be no fun involving
them bus suddenly Clare goes to this
giant door and says I'm funny computer
comic relief open up the door yeah
insane the guy fan just killings
suddenly the door starts to open up
there's nothing but darkness facing
earth well shit could it be she stares
into the black unknown while lighting up
a flare
[Music]
Claire throws the flare towards coat to
an original coqu's light
[Music]
so there they are Raptors giant co2
Raptor and the motherfucking t-rex all
in the kick-ass incredible show now hang
on if we're gonna do this we got do this
right oh hello John Bailey I know you're
used to doing the honest trailer voice
and your own reviews on your own channel
plug but I need your help with what
exactly
oh I need a voice as epic as yours to
narrate the climax of Jurassic world the
motherfucking t-rex scene mm-hmm
done the t-rex takes a bite out of the
pussy Saurus but that pussy sword spikes
back the t-rex legs that bitch into a
pill baby
but then the bitch trips over to the
ground t-rex then starts taking several
bites to the neck suddenly one of the
grounders jumps on top bring the t-rex
she knocks the head back slamming pussy
soros into one of the overly priced
restaurants the t-rex then says you
cannot defeat such awesomeness well
she's a female who happens to sound like
Optimus Prime
yeah okay you cannot defeat such
awesomeness my amazing kick a serine
cannot be contained the reported war
then the motherfucking t-rex would been
a mechanical t-rex came in and burn them
alive okay I know that didn't happen in
the movie
who's got the cool voice okay sorry but
they survived the blast and blow him up
with their own fire breath t-rex then
gives her opponent one more chance
surrender or face the age of extinction
no response
thus the motherfucking t-rex replied
that go fish suddenly that cool jaws
dinosaur who saw her here comes up and
beat the living hell on a piece of shit
the battle is over t-rex and Raptor two
sworn enemies acknowledged that their
honor has been satisfied and live to
fight another day
oh and some stuff with human characters
happens but who cares the t-rex climbs
to the tallest building on the tallest
mountain overlooking the park lets up
one more triumphant roar turns to the
camera and says I am a motherfucking
t-rex damn you not only did you create
one of the coolest scenes in any
Jurassic Park movie ever but you totally
made up for that shitty ass fucking
idiot sequence in Jurassic Park 3 yeah
remember when the t-rex dies - the who
cares a soros just so they can sell more
toys but this scene takes all the
fucking idiots who thought this was a
good idea who grabs him by the ear and
says come come here no no that is not
how you do a t-rex fight movie that is
how you do a t-rex fight this is how you
do a t-rex fight you idiots those are
bad god dammit movies I was just about
done with you I swear it was over I was
just about to head out the door and be
like I'm sorry Jurassic Park sequels
this abuse can go on to longer if you
promise so many wonderful things for us
and instead you hurt me you hurt me time
and again well no more goodbyes Jurassic
Park sequels couple what if I made the
greatest t-rex fight have
I'd say I'm falling for your bullshit
all over again
love me Jurassic Park sequel yes it's
like frost/nixon the majority of the
interviews aren't very good but the last
few minutes practically makes up for all
of it
I guess really the films not the worse I
mean it is well acted looks nice and
does have some remarkable scenes I just
wish I didn't have to sit through so
much boring stuff to get to those scenes
if you want to suspense them great make
the effects better and give us more
scary scenarios if you want to do a beat
Phil great go all out make some totally
insane choices make the whole film as
good as that last ten minutes but this
happened half thing why can't I quit you
Jurassic Park sequels I guess it's the
film's go it is the second best out of
all of them but given the other two it's
not a phenomenal feat a lot choices they
make do still piss me off but I'm not
gonna be shocked if other people like it
for a lot of people it's stupid in all
the right ways for me I didn't think it
went far enough except for that ending
which like I said is totally worth the
price of admission yeah I realise this
review is all over the place should you
see it should you not see it but
hopefully you can get some idea this is
the right movie for you so is that it
then yeah pretty much
there's nothing else to reenact though
the studio that owns this does also own
Fifty Shades of Grey and it's unlikely
to let me use the cliff's from that No
okay no my inner goddess is about to
explode be sure to subscribe to this
crazy guy for his movie reviews and
check mine out on my channel because I
said so in my cool voice
[Music]
I think it's part Raptor